[Música]
[Aplausos]
voy a compartir este viaje
con usted
y nos vamos a ubicar en tiempo y espacio
fines de la década del 80 y tenía que
definir cuál iba a ser mi camino
por alguna razón
elegir el camino del zar para la Sara
y así fui tratando yo ahora delante mi
primer emprendimiento
hice limpiar todos los tanques de agua
de la ciudad
y el segundo cliente le está petado la
cañería
después intenté con otro emprendimiento
nuevo
pues un bazar en un barrio de la ciudad
donde la Square era una herencia
familiar
fracaso segur
entendí que
y me rendí a no aprendía así que fui por
algo más
compré una distribuidora
completa prestada y la usura que todavía
estoy pagando la ALBA
y obviamente un nuevo fracaso
0 para emprender
era la elección y seguramente necesitaba
capacitación así fue a la empresa
familiar
que me acogió y empecé a ser mi
entrenamiento de repositor
el salón he encargado la sucursal
encargado
de las finanzas
pero algo se venía gestando que no lo
veía y posiblemente en el emprendimiento
familiar
serían momentos muy duros y muy oscuros
a media de 95 nos encontramos con una
convocatoria de acreedores
para hacer luego una quiebra
un momento extremadamente doloroso y
difícil muy difícil
pero la vida
siempre te regala algo para compensarte
María Eugenia mi primera hija el amor de
mi vida
aún así
tratando de entender que mi camino era
el ser para el azar
decidí que en algún momento iba a volver
a ser emprendedor de mi propia idea
nuevamente
fresa fini del
2001 inside me llego y la idea de
poner en un sobrecito azúcar una
delicatessen
para acompañar a todos los cafés la
Argentina fue milusion fue mi convicción
en las condiciones adecuadas
estaba totalmente fuera del sistema
quebrado sin recursos
posiblemente muy golpeado
pero la convicción en la tan alta que
así me lancé la idea era más fuerte el
sueño
era mucho más grande
sin saber mucho del industria
alimentaria me fui alquilar una
panadería nocturna
pedir plata prestada como siempre
maestro chocolatero
y me lancé sin escalas Rosario
petit fours habías llegado a la ciudad
no fue fácil no fue para nada fácil
inicio
principio del 2001 en ningún momento
considere que había sido un nuevo
fracaso no le podía venir nada a nadie
hasta que la creatividad o la necesidad
me subo a decidir que lo tenía que
regalar
y la idea de vestir el café expreso era
mucho más fuerte que la realidad
Telepizza regalar
así la ciudad me conoció los lugares de
tendencia
lo empezaron a incorporar y el mercado
rosarino me visualizo
tuve la posibilidad de crecer
rápidamente en la ciudad pero no era
suficiente para mis sueños
cines Carmen Santa Fe y sigue adelante
la misma acción
empezar regular la mercadilla empecé a
mostrarme y darle visibilidad
y Santa Fe me acogió
pero quería más mi sueño era más grande
Córdoba era el nuevo destino
muy convencido muy entusiasmado con
mucha energía con mucha pasión
me fui a Córdoba sin ver lo que
realmente estaba sucediendo a fines del
en ese momento no hace falta que le diga
Argentina vive un momento muy especial
yo me encontré desarrollando el mercado
de Córdoba
cuando en realidad las condiciones ni
siquiera me permitían salir de la ciudad
porque en esta ciudad social se había
hecho daño en Argentina
creí que hasta ahí había llegado mi
sueño seguramente entendí que podía ser
el final
no tenía muchas opciones o me rendía
o continuaba no sabía cómo pero tenía
que continua
dios aprieta pero no ahorca
llegaba Tomás
y segundo hijo
el amor de mi vida
aún así
creo que lo usé como una turbina
para seguir adelante
y me fui a hacer uso San Luis San Juan y
Mendoza para después hacer Neo
Mesopotamia litoral
el norte argentino
tenía que continuar aún con las
condiciones absolutamente difíciles
pero emocionalmente
estaba muy inspirado salió bien
lo logré hasta que la vida nuevamente
empieza a distribuir las cartas
en el 2003
muere papá me hubieran mentor
cómo emprender es una emoción por lo
menos para mí
tienes oportunidad creía que realmente
había llegado mi final
supongo que con alguna bendición que
desconozco hasta ahora hoy de donde vino
un impulso me subo para adelante
tenía un pequeño utilitario
que fui y lo liquide en el mercado por
la plata que me dieran
mañana en 17000 pesos por eso te
literario y alguien desconocido
del universo sigo a mí y me dijo que
escribe esto lo tenéis que llevar a unos
aires
al principio no lo entendí y me negué
pasaron las horas y entendí que ya no
tenía nada que perder
la feria gastronómica
Argentina en Costa Salguero y puse 16000
pesos en el stand
y 1000 peso me guarde para estar 4 días
en Buenos Aires
el milagro me esperaba
el mercado corporativo de la gastronomía
argentina
está hecha
radical
pero uno de ellos posiblemente lo que me
esperaba y no lo sabía era McDonald's
en algún momento la Corporación decidió
que ese producto de Carcarañá ni Google
Maps nos toma
quería que estuviera lo de su café
así fuimos con mucho trabajo con mucha
labor con mucho empeño y pudimos cumplir
con todas las exigencias de la
corporación en el año 2004 entrábamos a
Buenos Aires de una de las marcas más
importantes del mundo
fue como un caballo de Troya
una vez que estábamos en la ciudad todo
el resto de las empresas corporativas
querían tener Pettiford vistiendo sus
cafés
una etapa muy linda no paramos de crecer
no paramos expandirnos
en algún momento tuvimos posibilidad sin
pensadas la vida tenía sorpresa para
nosotros
pero no me cansaba quería más
quería que mis sueños fuera más lejos
que quería que llegará más lugares
y entendí que si va mi momento para irme
a explorar mercados del exterior y así
fue cuando le he España como el próximo
paso a repetir lo aprendido soy un
empírico
y la Feria de Barcelona me esperaba
mejor muy bien había capitalizado todo
el tránsito que había hecho está ese
momento
con la alegría de que el negocio de
España era triple más grande que el
Argentina
no tenía capacidad
me volví y me puse a modificar ampliar
la capacidad para poder atender el
mercado español un año cuando volví en
el 2009 la peor crisis española el
historia se había adueñado a la realidad
claramente las condiciones ambientales
del mercado me expulsaron
cambio de mercado
no me rendí jamás nos Estados Unidos
Nueva York Fancy Food
en la capital del imperio no puede haber
crisis pero me equivoqué mercado
sigue ofrecerles una cortesía para el
café expreso
y los gringos me pedían donas muffin
cookies
hasta creo que vino en Los Simpson a
buscar una dona eso tenía un producto de
4 g me equivoqué me equivoqué en
realidad
después aprendí que no es una
equivocación es un aprendizaje
y cambié mercado me vine a Brasil
cipal la feria más grande de televisión
brasilero me esperaba fue fácil pues más
fácil que lo anterior cliente
corporativo de la Argentina tenía un
presencia en Brasil
y el ingreso al mercado un poco más
rápido
2011 empezó a trabajar con la capacidad
que tenía instalada y las posibilidades
que me abrí el mercado brasilero y
empecé a crecer al cabo del primer año
los costos habían aumentado un 25 y el
precio venta 1 5
si vamos esto es esto es el viaje esto
es avanzada seguimos 2012
Onfray lante infracción del precio venta
inflación de los costos 30
bienvenido a la Argentina
me tuve que retirar no había forma de
sostener lo que hice una crisis
importante en el 2013 para darme cuenta
de que lo que había transitado en ese
viaje es haberme enamorado
semi product petit fours
pero no me dejaba satisfecho
fue cuando entendí que en la crisis hay
una oportunidad
y llegó el momento de ampliar la familia
no era en cortesía para el café la
decisión sino que eran las cortesía del
ensalada de las papas fritas del postre
de los helados de los yogures
la creación no había sido el producto
había sido la idea
empezamos a transitar con mucho esfuerzo
un camino de un nuevo crecimiento
en mercado argentino nos había dado
nuevamente una oportunidad
el mercado sí pero la vida parecía que
no
el 2015 para que me encontrará con
la pérdida de mi hermano
otro momento
aún así
emprender es emocional
y Gustavo
es muy emotivo
tenía que seguir
las condiciones laborales estaban dadas
el empuje y la fuerza era muy grande
crecíamos
participamos creamos
pero parecía que había más
en 2017 se va mamá
Jackson los procesos de la adultez a sea
no tenía techo ya no me quedaba nadie
arriba
y lo único que tenía en el amigo
juristas
volvió a intervenir me para poder
continuar
obviamente mis amores me sacaron ante
cada caída
pero parecía que
siempre hay más sigo 2019 y llego Kovic
nuevamente
cómo nos alimentamos una fanta mo como
interpretamos
cómo distinguimos cuál es la salida cuál
es el camino cuál es la esperanza
crisis oportunidad fue cuando detectamos
de que haciendo lo mismo pero para el
mercado hogareño
podía llegar a tener una oportunidad
hoy con un equipo de 100 espartanos
4 plantas
auditoría de calidad internacional
cumplidas
estamos en el proceso de la reinvención
de la transformación de Petit
no sé si mi historia
voy a inspirar a muchos
pero hay un tema que si quiero compartir
con ustedes
nunca jamás dejen de soñar
por favor
[Aplausos]
[Música]